hey everybody I'm getting a message that
my my stream status is bad so let me
know if you can see this if you can hear
me
my seeing anything in the live chat I
know there's a delay but alright awesome
now I got it's kind of a long delay on
this alright so yeah I had some some
issues like two minutes before I was
going to start the stream where
everything was freezing up so I shut
down my my webpack server and my goal
server that I was running and I close
some windows so hopefully hopefully
everything will run all right I have up
on the screen just kinda the same
reminder that I've had for a while I'm
not really going to go over it strings
are going to be sporadic the next couple
of days and then next week it will get
back on schedule the only thing I do
want to know is I'm going to be at
syntax con I do have permission to do
video there either live stream or
pre-recorded video so if there's
something in particular in particular
that you all would like to see please
let me know you can let me know the live
chat when the comments or on Twitter
however you prefer
okay let's just checking it yeah it
looks like the stream is good nobody's
nobody's saying there's anything wrong
with a stream so just a recap from
yesterday where yesterday if you if you
were washing it was uh I got stuck on
one step of setting up the server a
really easy and early step and that's
setting up an alternate user account so
we don't have to use route all the time
and the problem was when I went to copy
and paste the SSH key I didn't get the
entire key so I was trying to go quickly
didn't get the very end of the key and
when I pasted it in obviously it didn't
work so that was the problem so it's
kind of nice that it wasn't you know
something more serious but that happens
so I should have thought I know later on
some people in the livestream suggested
that it might be that issue then as soon
as I saw this suggest and I I kind of
knew that that was probably it so that's
that was the problem so now I do have a
user and it does work so we're going to
login today as this user I set the
length for this live stream for an hour
instead of a half an hour because I'd
like to get through as much the server
setup as I can hopefully all of it
that's a little bit ambitious
so we'll see we have to install nginx
and node we'll probably set up on maybe
we'll set up the SSL I might wait since
the URL that we're going to use it's
just a test URL it might not be the real
one so we'll see and then hopefully we
can get a chance to configure our server
our node server using we're going to use
Express and see if we can actually get
this this app running the site running
on the server so I don't know if I can
get it done
go longer than an hour I have a meeting
at 1:00 p.m. Eastern Time
so I can't go any longer than that and
it is a meeting about this website so
I've been working like crazy to try to
get a lot of the changes requested at
the last meeting done they were
basically just minor user interface
changes just some content changes and
things so nothing big I got most of them
finished I do this show to kind of show
you how what things are like for me so
I'm not I'm not usually one to complain
that much I don't like it but just to
let you know how things are going and be
completely honest I'm starting to get a
little bit burnout because I've been
working a lot of hours so just just to
give you an idea just to show you I'm
going to throw up by my tracking of my
hours I know this is probably small but
you just see the colors so this is my my
time sheet so in a normal day I'm
contracted to work seven hours so
anything green is over seven seek you
can see the additional hours are all
here so I'm like at least a week of
overtime now just for this month and
we're only halfway through the month I
don't this so this is like just a lot of
work for me recently and the frustrating
thing was you know yesterday I put in
like eleven and a half hours but I think
at least six hours of that was spent in
meetings so I don't know that's just a
crazy amount of meetings for me that's
above average but it's kind of it's
frustrating we got a tight deadline and
that happens so it might not be like
this for all front-end developers but
sometimes it just happens you got to put
in a lot of hours because you have a
deadline
there's there's interruptions so I ended
up going home and doing some work at
home
the tough thing was I was supposed to
take my son to his karate lesson and I
couldn't I had to text my wife from a
meeting to tell her I wouldn't make it
so that's that stuff I'm not going to
get to see my kids for a couple days
this week because I'll be at a
conference so I really wanted to be able
to spend more time with them but instead
I ended up going home and doing more
work and then putting them to sleep and
staying up and doing more work so now
I'm now I'm tired and I'm running on on
caffeine so with that said I'm still
going to try to do my best get this done
on time and be happy at my meeting but
that's that's just how it goes it's not
always like this but occasionally you
get a project with the tight deadlines
in and this is just how it is so sorry
for the you know the complaints the
little whining session but I just want
to let you guys know how it is you know
without sugarcoating it so hopefully
next week we launch and things will slow
down enough for me to get back to a
normal schedule and also when you're
working this fast you don't get the time
to try out new things and learn new
things which I like to do on projects
hey everybody everybody's saying hi in
the livestream which I always like to
try new things but when you have a tight
deadline do it you just have to fall
back on what you know will work and what
you've done in the past so you don't
really get to to develop as much at
least that's been in my experience so
hopefully I get a project with a more
reasonable deadline next and you can try
out some some new cool stuff all right
so enough about that let's get to it if
you want to follow along and I'll say
this right off the bat I'm going to
ignore the live stream a little bit but
at the end I'll try to catch up but I
think the only way we're going to get
through most of this
is if I don't take very many breaks to
answer questions in the livestream if I
do miss your question like and you have
to go and you can't stick around for the
whole livestream I'll try to answer it
at the end or you can put it in the
comments and I'll send an answer to you
when I get a chance to see it later on
so in the description I've linked to two
tutorials on digitalocean the first one
we did yesterday and that was how to set
up a boon to on a digital ocean droplet
the second one is what we're going to
start with today and that's how to
install nginx I just so somebody yeah
somebody was there yesterday and that's
what was it was the issue it was it was
a copy and paste error it's kind of
embarrassing but I was just trying to go
too fast and didn't double-check that I
copied everything that the problem was
actually normally I would open my like
my SSH key on my machine I would open it
in an atom and then I would see the
whole thing it'd be easier to copy and
paste but I didn't actually want my my
key to show up on the screen so if I
would have opened it an atom and just
Auto opened it it probably would open
right on the screen that I was on since
I had Adam open on that screen so
instead I thought well I'll just use
Nano to open it
whoa evidently uh it's a little bit more
difficult to copy and paste in Nano
maybe it's just me because I don't do it
a lot but that's that's why I did it so
I thought I got it all
when I was at trying to copy it from
nano but I didn't that happens I guess
all right so we're going to step one of
that nginx tutorial I think it's the
second one I linked in the description
oh no the links are broken alright let
me throw your link right now and the
live chat see if this one works
thanks for the heads-up about the broken
links I will try to fix that after this
videos for people watching later can can
get the right links alright so you don't
really need to follow along it
Anton if you don't want to with the
instructions but it might provide a
little bit more explanation I'm gonna
make this a lot bigger so we can see
that should be big enough let me know if
it's not I can make it bigger first
things first we're gonna log in there we
go see it works yeah necessarily spend
so much time one I get I mean it was at
least 10 minutes right that we spent
trying to figure that out and couldn't
figure it out so it works now alright so
step one remember we're going to use
sudo now because we want to we need to
have root privileges to be able to run a
lot of these commands so that's why we
use sudo in front of almost everything
we use it for and then we're going to
say apt-get update so this is just going
to update this this is like the package
manager for Ubuntu the apt-get we're
going to update the package manager when
you're using sudo usually the first time
you use it you type your password in and
then if you use it very like quickly
after that they don't make you type your
passwords you won't have to type it all
the time alright so we're up to date and
now we're going to run sudo apt-get
install nginx alright and let's see it's
just warning me about how much disk base
I'll have left after I install this on a
good yes everything we're installing
today should fit on a five
dollar-a-month digitalocean droplet at
least it did the last time I did that
which wasn't too long ago maybe a few
months ago all right step two we need to
adjust the firewall if you remember
yesterday we had a firewall and we
allowed open SSH
well now we have nginx and we need to
allow nginx to work with the firewall
because nginx is going to need to
communicate with the outside world with
people requesting to check out the site
so let's just list and see what we have
okay so all these right now are
possibility that we can open up we're
going to at least right now we're going
to enable HTTP since we don't have an
SSL setup okay so that's our command
really simple straightforward UFW allow
and then we type the name in single
quotes we type the name of the
application we want to allow all right
let's let's just check this let's check
the status to see okay and we have it on
the list as being allowed
now we're going to actually start the
web server so the command we're going to
use this is step 3 on the documentation
if you're reading it okay this just lets
us know let it start it so we can see
it's active running okay it's been
running for about two minutes and we're
actually going to we're going to go to
the page just to make sure that it's
working and in the instructions it says
go to the IP address but I've already
pointed this sub domain to our IP
address so if all you do if you've never
pointed a subdomain before you go into
wherever you have your domain hosted at
whatever your registrar is or if you've
changed your name servers wherever those
names are is appointed to you go in
there should be a place where it shows
you all the different subdomains that
are associated with your domain where
the MX records are that handled an email
for that domain and you can just add
another one type with the name you want
for the subdomain in this case it's test
and then you want to select what's
called an a record you put your IP
address in that a record save it and
then your sub domain will point to where
you want to go when you're messing with
that stuff just a word of advice take
screenshots or or something to remember
everything all the configuration because
if you mess it up and you don't remember
what it was supposed to be it could it
could really mess up your site people
won't be able to get to your site it
could possibly make it so that email
doesn't work on that domain so you don't
want that to happen especially if you're
working on a big site or client side you
know site that has maybe
a lot of subdomains you know you just
you want to be careful about that so
make sure you you only edit what you
need to edit and you have a backup so
you can restore it if you need to all
right so that's working so we'll move
that off and I just glanced yeah I did
say yesterday we would disable the root
user so we have we didn't do that did we
okay for some reason I thought that that
was part of those instructions that we
are following along maybe it was in a
different spot so I'm not going to try
to find it right now in the middle of
the video if we have time later on I'll
try to do it or at some point out I'll
try to find it explain it but yeah I do
I really do want to disable the root
user and I did forget to do that
yesterday so thanks for bringing that up
I'm actually just going to type that in
the search bar and leave it there so
that I see it when we're done
okay let me get back to my tutorial
okay so we're going to skip a little bit
in tutorial since we don't really need
this um let's see okay we can go to step
four step four is just going to show us
how to stop and start engine acts how to
restart it we're not going to go through
these because we we haven't changed
anything yet this just shows you the
commands in case you're not following
along we run sudo systemctl all together
start engine X we can do the same thing
but just instead say restart engine X
just stop and start immediately when one
command we can reload engine X which can
be used if you change the config but you
don't want to actually stop and start it
and mess up your connections you can
just reload and then the changes will be
enabled engine X will restart by default
it will start if you reboot your server
you can disable this and it's the
command is just enable disable engine X
these are all assuming we're saying sudo
systemctl first then disabled engine X
and then to re-enable it you you just do
enable engine X so those are all really
straightforward
step 5 if you're falling along just goes
over some of the directories that are
important for engine X and that's it for
now for this for this part of it we are
going to
let's uh do you get well let me let me
ask you would you like to see how to set
up an SSL because we can do that step
now or we can just skip it and try to do
it later
I'm going to wait a second just for the
delay to see if I get any response here
I'll go ahead and bring up that tutorial
just in case we do want to do that okay
we've got a yes I'm going to copy and
paste the link to the next tutorial in
the live chat and then I will add it
into the description as well
after the video after the live stream
ends so if you want to follow along
we're using is the basic instructions on
digital ocean for how to secure nginx
with let's encrypt on Ubuntu and the
first thing we need to do is install
cert but so let's I'm just going to copy
and paste this because it's a long one
okay so this is going to install cert
but for us
all right we need to confirm by hitting
answer great okay we're going to update
our package list right I'm sorry I said
the first command would install it this
is pre prerequisite command so obviously
that the apt-get install command is what
really installed it I am going really
quickly you can read more about what's
happening well right now it's actually
installing it but you can read more
about it in the the instructions on
digital ocean that I just length
okay
let's we're going to be on step 2 now
and we're going on the web route plug-in
and so the web route plug-in if you not
following along I was summarized a
little bit what it's saying it needs to
check a file in the directory that's
cooked it's going to be dot well-known
it's going to be the name of the
directory so we need to allow access to
that directory so we're going to edit or
nginx config to allow access to that
directory so let's go and I'm going to
show you in the instructions it says use
Nano to do this but I have an easier way
so let me bring this up here if you've
never seen this before I know the fonts
really small I'm not I'm not sure how to
make the font bigger on this right away
so sorry about it being small
this is FileZilla it's just the client
that normally you can use to like FTP
and to server in this case I've set it
up with with SFTP so it actually uses
the same SSH key that we were using the
SSH in on the terminal I like this
better because I can open the file in my
code editor which is Adam on my my local
machine and it's so much easier for me
to edit this then if I try to edit it
with Nano
so that's where I'm going to differ a
little bit from these instructions it's
entirely up to you some people are
really good with terminal editors
especially some people were just like
really really good with them and can go
really fast I'm not one of those people
so we're going to go to the directory
that says we need the
actually the theaters work now I
remember what happened last time I did
this hmm
all right the last time I did this I
remember I think I had an issue with
this because my user did not have access
to these files so normally you'd have to
run a syn sudo so the way around this is
actually I guess it's actually good at
this point that we didn't disable the
root user I don't recommend doing this
or leaving this this option open but for
now this will speed things up for us I'm
going to actually make the user root and
now I'm going to shut it a previous
connection now I'm going to try to go in
with this okay there is a way that I
could have just let my user edit those
files and log in like that but I don't
want to have to do that because it will
just take more time right now but that's
probably the better way if if you had
more time but for now we can work we do
this then we'll switch it back to using
my user and then at some point we can
just totally disable the root user but
this should speed things up for now if
anybody has more experience with this
and this is like really crazy let me
know if there's some reason why I really
should not do this I would like to know
all right so we need to get it going to
nginx it is and sites available and
default so I'm going to click view /
edit and there we go so now let's open
this file and Adam and it's so much
easier to edit like this okay so now
we're going to continue on we're going
to add this ssl to the server block
so this is Oh when you see your nginx
config when you see this hash sign
that's basically like a comment tag so
these are all commented out there's a
lot of stuff that's you know just
examples of what you could use so we
want to add this inside our server block
so this is our server block it's a
server and then we have this open
bracket and then it closes where's it
clothing at all the way down here okay
so closing lay down here so a lot of
this stuff is commented out at this
point but we're going to just add this
location under here it should be good
right there we'll certainly find out
saying if it's not but I'm pretty sure
that'll work
I just saved that so I just hit control
s or command S and we're going to hit
yes and now this is saved on the server
if I had left it to where the user we
were using for for this was Jessie
instead of root when I would have tried
to save it it would not have let me save
that because I wouldn't have had right
access to that file okay let me know if
I'm going too fast or if I'm losing any
of you and I can I can always try to
explain a little bit more or slow down a
bit okay we've gotten through the first
half hour and you're not I'm not too bad
on time we'll see if we get through it
all and now let's go back to our
terminal
and we're going to do sudo nginx T this
is going to check if we have syntax
errors in our config file and everything
is okay awesome since we don't have any
errors I'm going to restart nginx
so I'm not going to type this all out
but you can see it's systemctl restart
nginx and we've obviously you suit up
okay so everything's restarted and they
give us the next step is a really long
command where it wants to know the path
for our Webber and the the name of our
domain so what I do I'm going to copy
this and then I'm going to come over to
Adam I'm going to copy in here and edit
it here since it's easier to do it here
than on the command line I can take
advantage of the slight benefit of
multiple cursors so we have test our
catechetical comm it doesn't matter how
many times I try to spell that we're
catechetical is always hard to spot see
it easy to kiss okay I think I did it
right and I think this is the default
path for nginx so I'm assuming that this
dis will work because we didn't change
our path okay so now I'm going to copy
that paste it okay enter email address
okay so now this let's encrypt is going
to ask some questions to set up the SSL
so okay so that's my work email and
I'm just going to agree and share your
email address yeah sure they can send me
stuff and you see we're getting a new
certificate uh-uh
oh shoot I forgot to put WW for my I
wasn't thinking so if you want to do a
sub-domain and you want it to be
reachable with with or without the WWE
actually have to make two records and I
don't know why I forgot to do that
because I've I've done it a lot but for
some reason I forgot
so actually I don't really care about
that right now so what we're going to do
is let's just go back here and let's
take out the w w since this is a test
I'm not I'm not worried about it so we
are gonna have to go through this again
so just be was it like 15 seconds last
time
congratulations it works see if you I
was going to go in and change that
record for this sub-domain I would just
put W W test and then I would point the
a record to the same place we will do
that when we switch it over the main
domain for the site is just going to be
catechetical com
we'll do that then but for now since
it's just test it's not really worth the
effort
alright so we have our certificate and
it's that easy to get in SSL so there's
really there's no excuse to not have an
SSO it was free and it takes five
minutes
Oh somebody did comment if you're using
I is it is a bit different
so yeah Windows is a GUI base so yeah it
is different totally different
instructions for that and I don't work
with it we have other people here that
work with the Windows servers and so
I've never had to I don't even know how
to do that okay let's go next step
it says we can check if the files are
there I'm not going to check because I'm
pretty sure the default locations always
always works I'm just going to skip that
for now but if you wanted to there's if
there's a command you can use to check
to make sure that your your your keys
for your SSO are there we want to
generate now a a strong diffie-hellman
group okay so I am going to do this it
does take a few minutes but it looks
really cool on your terminal when it
happens so let's let's do this so this
is the command that we're going to use
it's super long so once again we copy
and paste this is what I say it looks
kind of cool
I like this I like this thing I once was
doing this at home and we had somebody
visiting and they saw my screen and like
asked me throw some sort of hacker or
something because they thought it looked
really crazy which I'm not but it does
look really cool okay so while we're
waiting on that I'll check the little
bit in the live chat someone says a PC
user they're not familiar with the Linux
patch yeah unfortunately things are
going to be slightly different if you're
doing this on a PC some of the commands
are the same and one thing to remember
too I am now logged into a Linux server
so I'm no longer on my local machine so
even if you're on a PC if you SSH into
the Linux server you're using Linux
commands so unless you're using a
Windows server these are going to be the
commands you're using whether and it
doesn't matter how you access that
server you can access it through the
browser through digital
admin panel you could be using I mean
you can access through the browser on on
Chrome OS you can be on a Mac Windows or
Linux but no matter what you're still
executing these commands on a Linux
server so even if you are on a PC it is
good to know these linux commands
because odds are at at some point you
know unless you're going to be doing
like strictly you know Microsoft based
like dotnet development then at some
point you're probably going to do some
work on a Linux server yes you see this
does take this they go up it should be
done soon it's been a minute or two
already I'll just skip ahead a little
bit on the instructions on step three
we're going to configure SSL on the web
server so if you remember at first
talking about the the firewall which
will switch later on but in the firewall
we did not allow nginx to serve AC TPS
and then in the nginx config we only had
things going through port 80 which is
the normal port for regular HTTP traffic
but we need to switch it up and go
through allow SSL traffic to go through
I think the port is 433 I think that's
the default port the wind up using 443
sorry 443 so we will need
we need to go to our configuration files
again as soon as this is done
I could probably log in on a separate
tab if it starts taking too long and try
to get some of the other stuff done and
Alberto and the live chat you suggested
if you want to practice with a Linux
server use VirtualBox and install Ubuntu
on it yeah that's that's good advice if
you don't want to actually pay for a
Linux server or you can use I mean
doesn't have to be able to you can use a
different version of Linux if you want
you can probably do it in docker as well
if you use a docker container with
whatever version of Linux you want I'm
sure there's some other some other ways
that I'm I'm forgetting if you use
something like cloud 9 so that at sea 9
io they start you off with it's a cloud
development environment that you can
access through your browser and it was
free I think it's still free they give
you a terminal right there in your
browser and you can practice those
commands and there as well that's
probably the most user friendly of all
the options that that I mentioned that
I'm seeing here in the live chat I would
try cloud 9 isn't the only cloud
development environment there are a few
others as well so try try that out too
because then you don't have to know
anything about setting up your own your
own server it's already set up for you
and you can just practice the commands
well sorry guys this is taking longer
than I remember it taking okay all right
it works okay somebody mentioned them
that in the live chat
cloud9 is free but you have to get your
credit card info so you know what I do
remember that now when I signed up for
it you didn't and then they changed it
and now you do have to add a credit card
so you can still use it for free and
they won't charge your card but you need
to have a credit card for that so yeah a
little bit of a barrier to entry there
I'm trying to think did it get acquired
I the change came I think maybe right
after c9 got bought out that it was a
while ago this so I can't remember
exactly what happened okay so now let's
go to step 3 and we need to configure
nginx to use SSL we need to create a
config sentence mr.
all right so it's saying that we want to
use Nano to open this and edit and
create the the file but like I said I
don't want to use an ax so this is going
to differ sudo and instead of Nano I'm
just going to say touch and then I'm
going to copy some of this in so if
you're not familiar with the command
touch that just creates a file I'm
assuming that this will work on it blue
tube
I know it works on the Mac and we need
to change it to our domain okay and then
now we can bring up our FileZilla window
and we're close swear T in the nginx
directory here so now we just need to go
to snippets and here we go there's the
file we just created file size zero
because you don't have anything in it
yet but now we can view and edit it so
we're going I'm going to copy and paste
copy and paste our SSL stuff we need to
change example.com to our domain which
is catechetical I love that it
auto-completed that for me I don't have
to try to spell that out every time so
I'm going to save that and wait yes
and I don't think we need this file
anymore so we can go ahead and close it
out
okay the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to make another snippet and
when you could do this all in one config
file if you break things out into
snippets it can make your file a little
bit more clean so if you've done this
before this is not exactly how you do it
it you don't have to do it this way and
in fact I've seen different tutorials on
digitalocean
that do it you know either way so I
think it just depends on what would you
prefer and how long your config file is
going to be is whether or not you want
to break it out I don't know if there's
another advantage to it or not you can
let me know in the in the live chat or
the comments if if you know okay
all right about quarter after okay I can
probably do this for maybe another half
an hour I want to leave a little bit of
time to prepare for the meeting that I
have at 1:00 p.m. Eastern Time so let's
keep working we're going to go we're
going to make another file we need to
make another snippet here and I've just
copied the the path and now let's check
it out let me refresh this and you can
see it's appeared here let's edit
okay and they give us some uh some
boilerplate security config I may go in
and edit this at some point so but this
will work for now and I'm going to go
through all this right now but it's just
a lot of ways you can configure things
and they do they give you a link in the
in the directions where you can go to
read more on you know what these things
do so yeah so like I said these will
probably get adjusted at some point but
for now this will work so I just saved
that said yes and now that'll be it'll
be saved now we need to adjust our nginx
config so let's go back let's see if I
still have to still have it open there
we go I still have it open so our sites
available substituting them
so it's asking us to make a backup of
our current so that's this probably good
idea let's make it back up so let's
let's run this command is going to copy
this command because it's long I'll tell
you what it does though this is just
copying the CP it's going to copy this
file which is default and it's going to
make another file exactly like it that's
default dot bak that's our backup so now
we can we can mess with our default
without fear that we're going to break
everything you know beyond repair so now
we're going to open up that default
which we already had open over here su
su this is the default file so we don't
need to open it again if you never
closed it and inside the server block
you want to find that server listen 80
and we had this SSL configure so we're
going to modify this and we're going to
allow basically we're going to shut down
traffic on port 80 like unencrypted
traffic and make everything go through
through SSL so I'm going to copy and
paste some of this and then we are going
to have to put in our own our own domain
so anywhere we see example.com needs to
change and remember we haven't used that
ww but yeah actually we do want to
redirect all the WW stuff but we don't
want to yeah what we don't want is
wwe.com redirecting to the HTTPS version
of WWE champ
because we don't have an SSO for that so
either now or at some point later on
we'll have to redirect WWE traffic to
not use that WW and that should prevent
anybody from getting an error message
saying you know hey this there's no SSO
the site's not secure things like that
so let's go change this test
Dodd's catechetical comm oh man my
Spotify just quit on me
got a put on a second I mentioned in a
previous video that I always play music
in the background and it helps I don't
get distracted by voices uh you know in
my in my building and also it helps me
to talk louder
because you know everybody talks louder
and they have headphones on listening to
music okay alright I'm starting to slow
down a little bit on I think two reasons
one I don't want to mess this up into I
am a little bit tired today so sorry for
the slow pace for those of you who don't
know anything about this it's probably
better that I go slower if you're a
little bit more knowledgeable you might
be getting bored so I apologize okay let
me um
let me bring over just so you guys can
see where I'm at I want to actually
bring this over and this is those the
instructions on digitalocean that I
linked to earlier that way
you can actually see where I'm at and
follow along so we just did this step
and now we're on this step we're
actually going to start a completely new
server block here and let me duplicate
this as well so that when I switch over
I can copy and paste more easily because
I'm going to need to switch back and
forth so we need to go at the end of
this server block and we'll just make
another one I know a lot of this is
already here and we could just uncomment
it but I think it'll be simpler at this
point to just copy and paste what they
have and a tutorial maybe maybe not let
me see if it's close enough
then actually let's not let's do this
and now we can open another block here
and we don't need that closing tag
because we already had one down here we
can uncomment on this stuff so that will
open up for 443 to listen there and now
we need to include our snippets remember
we made those two snippet files and this
is where you think these could be added
in here but to make things less
cluttered we just include this and we do
need to change that example now whatever
we put in these snippets is going to
load as if it were right here in this
document but we don't have to to have it
all in there so it's kind of nice makes
a little bit more clean and let's see
alright this should work sent because we
are redirecting everything here anyway
so all this other stuff that was
uncommented it should be fine to keep it
in this server block instead of this one
actually let's move this one down - I'm
not on a percent sure that this
absolutely has to go here but we'll give
it a shot
so we've saved it I'm going to upload it
we're going to skip over this
alternative configuration here
because we don't want a low of oh such a
traffic right now now we need to adjust
our firewall
so I'm not going to look at the status
we can we already know we looked at it
earlier in the stream we know so far
we've only done HTTP and instead we're
going to copy and paste these first what
we're going to do is we're going to
allow full so we're going to allow nginx
full which would be both both types of
traffic and then we're going to delete
so this is kind of an odd way to do the
command and we're not saying disallow or
disable we're saying delete allow okay
which is scoops and I forgot there we go
forget that a little single quote now we
will check the status just to make sure
it worked and here we go so we have
nginx Kol
all right let's check our nginx if you
remember we did before we use this
command nginx - T and that checks for
syntax errors all right everything is
good so we did a good job I was a little
bit worried with my editing of that file
trying to do it quickly that I would
mess it up but no syntax errors might be
some logic errors but we'll find out
soon enough now we're going to restart
it so the changes will take effect okay
and here's we're going to do we're going
to do an SSL report and this will let us
know so I'll do it right here we do need
to change it to the domain that we're
using so test up catechetical con okay
we'll let that go we'll come back to in
a second is it'll take a minute we want
to set up Auto renew okay so this is
important the the biggest at least that
I know of the biggest
of using free SSL from let's encrypt is
that it expires I think it's every three
months yeah so every three months it's
going to expire you have to renew it so
if you don't want to have to mark your
calendar and manually renew then you
want to set it up to Auto renew so we're
going to go into this this crontab if
you're not familiar with cron I I
believe it's short for like
chronological so they're basically
things you can do at given intervals in
time sorts of things that will
automatically happen on your server so
the way to configure this it's it's a
little bit weird but it looks a little
bit weird but it makes sense once you
you know once you get used to and see it
so for this I am going to use Nanna so
it it actually gives you a choice to use
them or actually I've never used this
one uh but we're going to use Nano and
it even says Nano is the easiest switch
using to her Nano all right this is what
it looks like all this stuff up here
this is you know all just kind of
instructions it lets you know a little
bit more about it but we're going to
skip down here and just edit actually
can we let's let's just copy so we don't
mess it up we're going to copy and paste
and whoops what did I just do okay
that's weird
okay so I'm actually going to move this
so it's it's more closely aligned with
the spot it's supposed to be in because
this just shows you the the border I
don't think this space will mess it up
oh but we'll see when it's time to renew
let me know if it messes it up I can't
remember if I put the space in before or
not so let me just show it it it does
well I can we can just run it straight
from straight from here says run the
following command at 3:15 a.m. every day
you can choose any time actually so this
is C this is minute hour right so let's
change this and go to 104
the reason being everybody that's done
this tutorial in just on the default is
putting this in is the time to renew so
maybe it would be a little less stress
on their system if if we renew it a
different a different time I mean I'm
sure they can handle it but just in case
we'll go set it for a different time
okay and then the rest of it is I mean
this renew is actually the come in we
want to run to renew the certificate
quiet means it's not going to output
information and it's not going to ask
questions and wait for us to input right
because we're not even going to be doing
this it's being done automatically so it
will get no input if it asks this part
of it is going to reload nginx if it's
actually renewed we do need to reload it
for the changes to take effect you
probably don't have to run this every
day so if we wanted to edit it you could
run it you know you have 90 days so
every day is probably overkill but it's
not going to
our system resources or anything to run
it every day if you wanted to so we're
just going to save and then if you're a
nano you save by hitting ctrl X to exit
that might be a little weird there's no
it doesn't say st. anywhere so you go to
exit but it's going to ask you first do
you want to save I'm going to type Y and
then it asks us what we want to name it
and we'll just go with whatever the
default is and so now we have the Auto
renewal set up and let's go back and
check our server setup all right and we
got an A Okay not bad I wanted an A+ I'm
not going to try to figure out why I got
the Y I got just the a right now
normally I can get an A+ on on a Linux
server so I'll have to figure that out
later on but an A is still pretty good
and that's it that's it for the SSL
portion of it I'm going to go now to our
our node setup and let me bring this
over I'm going to copy and paste this in
the live chat this is where we're going
now
and we're going to go so we've done all
these things right we've set up a bun -
we've set up our hostname we've done
we've set up nginx
and we have our SSL now we need to
install a node okay so let's just follow
the instructions I don't think I need to
do this because I'm already in the
directory I need to this will just take
me back to the home directory I guess
we'll do it just to be sure but I mean
you can see obviously I'm in I'm in the
home directory see I didn't actually
move anywhere so I'm just going to use
the default up probably if I if I have
more time maybe I would check to see
like okay is there a newer version I
usually do check and see you know is
there a newer version of this see when
this was done this was like November 1st
2016 it's not that that long ago but
maybe we might want to run into a
version of of node but this version
should be fun
and
[Music]
let's see we're going to run it I'm not
gonna inspect this I've done this before
when I run this I'm not going to expect
inspect it right now because we ran out
of time but basically this downloads the
script you need to install everything as
a bash script so it's like a set of
instructions that it'll run
automatically and now by running this
I'm basically saying hey up you know run
all those instructions in that batch
file so we can see it it's doing its
thing it's getting node it's getting it
at least all the all the stuff that we
need the next step is actually going to
you know run this install node all right
it actually tells us down here that the
next step is to run this to reinstall
it'll probably I'm guessing it will ask
us at some point if we want to do this
because it's going to take up some space
oh I didn't that's odd it usually does
okay now we're going to install this
build essential this is necessary okay
it asked me that time this is necessary
for some packages to work so we don't
have to install NPM separately you can
see here it says we've it's already come
packaged with what we had run previously
okay and just to make sure this works
we're going to okay I know I usually
don't go straight into Nano but this is
really simple so we're just going to put
it in there and all this is going to do
is I mean it this is JavaScript so this
should be somewhat familiar if you're
used to JavaScript we just have a
variable here a variable HTTP this
require HTTP okay so now we're calling
this HTTP we're going to create the
server right we're gonna give it a
content type and it's always going to
say is hello world it's going to listen
on 8080 that's like the default kind of
port that everything always is on and so
that's all it's going to do so a request
is going to go to nginx but it's going
to get passed along to note note is
actually going to process that request
and then pass it back out then well
that's that's the idea let's see if it
works
have we not gotten we might not have
gotten that far yet right we may have to
do some configuration for per engine
expert to work like that but we can test
it through the terminal as well so we're
going to control X
and save yep there we go
so we need to make that file executable
by default it is not so this is how we
do that now we can run it so now the
server is running right so it's running
on port 8080 so as we can we can test
this we have to open up another window
so let's see it's the stage at and what
is my let me find my IP that should work
there we go
and oops didn't copy
okay so Kuro if you're not familiar with
curl uh this is going to grab we give it
a URL and it's going to grab the data
from that URL and in this case the only
thing is a little world so it does work
now this is not ideal right we've lose I
don't need that right now this is not
ideal right we run this manually and
then it just sits here we have to open
up a whole nother tab or what happens if
some have you know this crashes we have
to log back in our server manually we
don't want that so we want it to
automatically we want to be able to
start it and then keep working in the
same tab and then have it automatically
restart if something were to happen and
there are different ways of doing this
in this case we're just going to follow
the default instructions here and we're
going to use p.m. - we can actually stop
this if you want to stop a process you
hit control
II hit control-c and then that stops
whatever server you're running and
that's the same way like if you're
running wet pack pack locally or you're
running a server with uh with gulp -
same thing control C alright so we're
going to install this that G flag means
globally so when you use NPM if you want
to install something for global use not
just in that particular folder you put
the G flag in the command alright and
now we can start this same thing with PM
- there we go
alright so we got a bunch of cool stuff
here and now it says that we have we
have this running it's the name is hello
and you can actually do have a custom
name there flags to be able to name it
whatever you want and it's online tells
you you do it gives you some stats about
it there's also a dashboard that you can
work in so if you go key metrics you can
have kind of this live dashboard that
runs in your browser so you don't even
have to use the terminal to check up on
the status of your application skip this
if you did this all right so we want
things to run when the server starts up
this is how we set that NPM - ah I
didn't notice it sudo that's kind of
weird guys the sudo there there we go
okay
all right so
we're going to copy this and let's
actually let's see if we can get the one
that it put out let me check the time
all right
hey we're going to be I got to wrap this
up so I get ready for my meeting we're
actually almost to the point where this
thing is going to run you know we just
have to finish up this and a lot of this
is not you can see some of its optional
that second step that I mentioned you
have to do with nginx this part is just
allowing nginx to pass through things to
the node server see and that's it so
really the only step you'd have to do
after this is just editing your server
block and nginx to look on to pass this
through to port 8080 for localhost and
that really is it and then at that point
instead of having it instead of starting
this hello j/s file that we did we get
rid of that hello j/s file we could
actually use get to pool or repo of this
next this react site that we're using
and we'd run and set we've been running
next we were running the dead version of
next let me show you yeah so we run
windowing yarn run dev okay but actually
I'll show you in my package JSON file
what we want to run if you're on the
server you can run you could run yarn or
if you don't want to spoil your on the
server you can just leave it with NPM
which is fine too so you can run NPM
next build
and that will build your application and
then start and when you start it now
that will be running instead of the
hello J s file so when someone goes to
your site they'll see your react
application I'm probably going to do
that later on today so I won't show you
that but really that's kind of of all
the steps we've just done it's not too
difficult to do the only tricky thing is
like you want to run this with p.m. - so
you want to make sure I have never
gotten yarn to work with p.m. - so I
always have to use NPM as the command
instead so like I said you would you're
on NPM
build in an NPM start but other than
that that's the only kind of trick that
I've ever the only snag I've ever run
into with that so so the long video
today don't have as many people sticking
around as we usually do I totally
understand this is kind of dry it's not
nearly as fun as the purely front-end
stuff which we'll get back to that
no more server videos now at least not
for a while so if you're sticking around
still thanks I know it was long I know I
I don't know if I could have stuck
around for this into our video I will
I'm not sure exactly when the next time
I'll be streaming is I will try to
stream the next couple of days when I
can from the conference or basically
from where where I can get good enough
Wi-Fi to stream otherwise I'll have to
do some pre-recorded videos and then
just upload them whenever I can get some
a good connection sorry I didn't get a
chance to go through all the live chat
today I will save this chat and I'll
look if someone had some some questions
that didn't get answered please post
them in the comments if not maybe I'll
try to save this and maybe in a later
livestream answer some of these
questions hopefully if you ask that your
your tuning
and again or can at least watch the
video later on oh cool I'm glad we had
some people so people were still here
they're still watching awesome good I'm
glad at least it means something you got
something out of this it's tough stuff
and you just got to practice it and the
thing is if you're doing front-end stuff
you won't really do this often enough to
really you'll memorize everything you're
always going to have to go back to the
instructions and there's all you're
going to be so parched that you just
forget and mess up on so that's how it
happens but it is something that you may
have to do one day so it's good to at
least have seen it at least once alright
so I only have a few minutes to get Sam
I'm eating now thank you so much for
watching I'll have some videos for you
soon and I'll see you maybe tomorrow
maybe the day after
have a great day